it's a new generation engaged in the
sort of confrontation that belongs in
the last century
they're teenagers many of them
encouraged to take part in the
unrest by their elders the late 1960s
saw the start of three decades of
conflict
what's happening here now isn't remotely
like that
but it's provocation and confrontation
nevertheless and it's the use of
youngsters
not old enough to vote in many cases
goaded on by adults
that has shocked people well i blame the
parents i mean
i'm i'm here with with my son who
if he had been out in the streets of
that age i'd of being horrified the
politicians here
have to really unite and come together
and condemn it and look for peaceful
ways forward for
you know the young people for the people
who don't think they're being listened
to at the moment during this process
these are the grounds of stormont castle
the seat of a devolved power sharing
government created by the good friday
peace agreement
signed 23 years ago hannah irwin was
born just before that
now she's leading the youth wing of the
alliance party
which covers the middle ground in
northern ireland politics
parents don't feel they have the ability
to stop their kids going out there
because the kids are being drawn out by
by community leaders
by people who are stoking violence and
stoking fears
they're being drawn out by them parents
can't really speak out against those
darker forces they can't stop their kids
going out because they know
if they're seen to go against community
leaders in that way
they could face attacks themselves they
could face threats they could face
anything there's deprivation in both the
loyalist and nationalist communities of
northern ireland
those who want a united ireland and the
loyalist areas where there's anger about
a border in the irish sea imposed by a
brexit deal
in many areas like this surrounded by
echoes of the past
it almost feels as if time stands still
difficult then for young people to avoid
the bad influences within this youth
leader has no doubt that
many of the young people are under the
firm grip
of paramilitaries no children should be
encouraged to take to the streets with
this kind of violence
those would amount to child abuse that's
that's that's something for the social
services to consider
in relation to this and even when we
think about the sinister forces that are
behind some of these
young people taken to the streets and
the element of their plan that could be
considered child abuse also
stephen and others like him have an
uphill battle on their hands
andrew simmons al jazeera belfast